so sorry about the old
bag an hour into dinner service and menu
Bingo is achieving its goal of customers
ordering a wide variety of items on the
menu I want to see his winning Joe said
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 I'm in second place
I'm wi now the pressure of the big night
is taking its toll on Joe there's too
much saffron on that there too much oh
Jesus Christ when anything goes wrong
the Cod looks like [__] look absolute
[__] Joe gets in that really stressed
out panicky mode why is that taking a
long time Joe I worry about Joe I worry
about stress level huh why is that
taking a long time uh because those
chickens just got cooked are you [__]
serious I need salt I'm very reactionary
I get stressed out for like 5 minutes
but you know what I just try to find
that comfort zone I could tune things
out if I want to Jean I'm leaving you
guys be now I got to run out there okay
looking for a little relief from the
intensity of the kitchen Joe takes a
stroll into the dining room hey how's it
going good how are you I'll see you in a
bit man okay we got we got a lot to talk
how's it going guys you guys have a
horrible habit of dropping every [__]
table in the restaurant at the same [__]
time CH good talking to you guys he's
like Houdini he's not around and you
have to pick up the slide Jean yeah it's
getting crazy out there now we got to
step up again yes all right guys come on
with Jean left alone in the kitchen one
musles left orders are backed up and
customers are now experiencing ing what
compa used to be known for slow service
we've been here for 40 minutes and I
haven't eaten yet we just had to do a
lot of things differently tonight we've
been here since 7:00 everything would
just took a while to come out it's
insane back there but uh no it's coming
right out I'm so busy right now I can't
even breathe right now everyone's
waiting for 2 hours for their food 9:00
is it really 9:00 it's 2 hours already
how long does it take to make spaghetti
I'm having l
they don't understand what's taking so
long I mean but at least if somebody
would came over on
the I have a table of like eight people
they're upset they want to speak to a
manager dropping table 20 hold on hold
on everybody shut up this is a [__]
cluster
Fu guys what's going
on I don't know what to say I don't I
was out at the table they had a
complaint they waited a long time uh
they weren't happy with the food I'm
sorry about what happens sorry that's
not exactly all right let me I I got I
got to run I got to run back there I'm
sorry but no I do I guess you really
do at that point you know I really
didn't want to be in that position and I
was really just trying to back away from
the
table the [__] pasta's going in while
Jean puts out fires in the kitchen the
angry customer is making her way to the
front of the restaurant and is now
complaining in front of Joe's mom she's
out there complaining to these people is
Joel I don't know I'm very disappointed
been here many many times I felt like I
was eating
Ragu I really did yeah that one out
there was saying the foods like ragon
she's out there I had the fish it was
great well somebody else had the fish
and it tasted like P Water I'm listening
to this witch I want to go Strang over I
was so aggravated I was so upset you
know that somebody would do that to my
son while Joe could not diffuse the
situation with the unhappy customer
shockingly a less than sober but
satisfied customer comes to the defense
of
comp why did you keep eating why did you
keep eating if it was that bad what's
her problem if it was that bad cuz you
the [__] Liars you just bought
everything for free you greedy [__]
[__] oh my in heaven you people are
mental go have another bottle of a wine
you [__] alcoholic [__] have another
bottle of wine you [__] L like who is
that
person okay tonight is a critical
crucial night are you with us or you I'm
just waiting for for him we're right
really busy right
now once again Peter has a debt
collector on his
doorstep well you are interfering that's
what I'm saying go the way he would you
mind inter I got to wait two minutes I
got to talk get out of the way what why
don't you go out the way so we can go on
get out of the way oh wait a minute I'm
talking to them why don't you go not get
out the way I want to talk to Y I'm say
go
relax relax relax relax
relax get the [__] who the [__] are you
relax relax D who the [__] you [__]
tough guy
[__]
[Applause]
[__] get tough guys come on you my
father come
onist I H you get head T
guys get the [__] out of here stop come
on you fake tough guy come on you fake
tough guy come on come on
me come on I'll put you in the hospital
yeah [__] yeah [__] come out the way
come out the way [__] this guy [__] this
guy come on you fake [__] Gangsta you
[__] [__] you're a [__] [__]
you're embarrassing me [__] this guy go
inside come on Peter Peter relax relax
relax who the [__] is he relax to come
in my [__] place relax relax relax
relax relax relax come on H my [__]
you scumbag get tough
guye right now right
now hey come on Big Boy take it easy
come in here come here come here [__] me
come in come in come in I'm sending Five
Guys to his house right now Jeremy and
guys are on their way right now who the
[__] is here give me this m
when it's the last [__] that's coming
in this place you're getting [__]
hotheaded why you see my father on the
floor I know so what do you mean I'm
getting hot I'm saying relaxed calm down
calm down calm down hey I told him to
get out are you okay they fight a lot
you know these things happen relax relax
relax relax let's get aside two seconds
walk fresh air come on with me let's go
for the first time in this guy's life
he's got to step up to the Mark Come Out
of The Shadow of his father and prove to
his mother and himself he's more capable
of running this business let me have the
phone no no no the phone stays here cuz
if he doesn't make it tonight he's going
to [__]
sink tonight is the beginning of the new
Seascape wipe your forehead you're
sweating I'm looking at the bigger
picture I got to prove to my father that
I can't control what's going on
completely new menu I'll have the uh
clam's Casino I'm having the seared
strip back great
thank you very much the weight staff is
revitalized by the influx of customers
and the new attitude at the Seascape and
table five fire please first 10 tables
are here um atmosphere is electric it
smells like a POA restaurant Peter now
has to get a grip understand what's
going on and host the ro we're looking
at probably about a 20 minute wait 100
customers Who coming at us and coming at
us hard we were swamped how are we going
to see those people and how long how
long time they going to
wait now it's to be messy trust me now
it's messy so far I think it's not going
that well to be honest right Peter this
is where we need to step up again now
I'm going to go talk to come on we go
step up big time let's
go me with the restaurant packed the new
chef and the veteran waitresses are
about to be put to the test everybody
keeps taking food out of here and it's
it's not me okay then it must be
Diane oh my God because you wanted me to
take P St right now I'm going to have a
heart attack These Girls Aren't used to
being [__] busy come
on okay this is where it's really
critical that a manager starts running
his bloody dining room because Peter's
restaurant is now in the [__] orders are
getting backed up the service is
starting to become slow kitchen's
falling behind pet you got to start
cracking the whip the kitchen is so
backed up I'm so sorry it's coming babe
it's coming hoping everything would go
so perfect and it just not the food's
just not coming out I've been waiting
for the uh Entre it's like 6:00 6:30
what's the matter my two kids still
haven't eaten and what would they
getting what were they geta and muscles
muscles are an appetizer I'll tell oh
Sky what Table Three did not get their
appetizers I mean they only been here
since freaking 6:30 that's going to that
goes on the back of the line that you
got to wait hold on let's get one thing
done in a ton I fired it a long time ago
and no no when you fired it it still
goes on the back of the line Peter and
the weight staff here they're too set in
their ways oh Scott when I order the
French on you automatically make them
for me right there no one telling them
what they can and can't do they're just
coming in they're taking what they want
they're just grabbing food is that yours
or mine Diane this this is mine it's
very
frustrating I can't communicate when
this is too stupid making sure the front
of the house is in sync with the kitchen
is Peter's responsibility and Irene is
losing her patience because he's not
stepping up and taking control please
somebody pick up this food my apologies
I'm
sorry M what are you want what are you
doing I can't believe this hasn't gone
out Mom what do you want mom kill me
brother take charge mom you know how to
rip into me for two days saying I'm
never going to grow up shut the [__] up
well this is why I never grow up mom you
are the boss start acting like one take
charge don't do this [__] mom take
charge all the little things mushroomed
into a big thing I'm sorry we're trying
the best this
weekend that's the table that just
walked out can you find out where Peter
is and ask what the [__] he's doing pet
Peter I don't know what I'm doing Peter
Peter I'm ready to give up my
RS my father right now is turning over
in his
[Music]
grave yes F hot in that
kitchen I'm concerned about Tom he's
sweating like a pig but and I don't know
what to say
I'll drive if you had too much don't you
worry come I got to call you quick
now right you're running around like a
[__] blue ass F yeah you're [__]
sweating like a pig get in the bathroom
and do something about it when Tom came
back could see he was just totally disor
like disarranged he you know he was
nervous he was nervous God it
stinks it's 45 minutes into dinner
service and though all appears to be
going well melt like butter
taste only a few customers have been
served and the mayor is not one of them
they got a meltdown down there and the
uh mayor yeah we can't keep him waiting
yeah does Michael know that that's a
mayor's table what table number is that
that's 12 yeah to make sure he knows you
understand I need the mayor's table man
I'm not getting tickets to this printer
right now why I don't know this printer
right here is not working I'm not
getting tickets through this computer
it's going to [__] me up no the
printer's
[Music]
working oh boy it was a disaster I've
already spoken to Dean about that and I
finally screamed cursed and yells get
someone in here to fix this now or we're
[__] I can't believe that no one's
coming in here to fix this [__]
computer but if nobody wants to hear it
nobody wants to hear it how about those
Stakes how about those Stakes he's
[__] standing with his finger up his
ass I don't know if Dean understands
that'll sink the whole night and you'll
be done oh God now we're seriously in
the [__] all the orders are backed up
tables are waiting Tom switched off but
more importantly we've kept the mayor
waiting 45 minutes of all the people to
keep waiting not the [__] mayor
Christ now more than an hour and 15
minutes into service and hungry
customers are getting restless
so
we feel it's been an hour we told
will come soon he getting a little out
of
control okay Michael what I need is the
[__] may now someone has to fix this
computer cuz I'm not getting
tickets unbelievable get me [__] Dean
yeah please sty away yes Dean we have to
go in the kitchen I need the mayor's
table man it's a [__]
hour it's not easy getting kicked in the
nuts every day and being told that you
suck I'm [__] embarrassed man where I
told you
this I don't have tickets for this why
aren't I getting tickets for this please
help me I don't have the ticket is what
I'm saying but [__] it this is the
copy you got to have the other half this
is not my ticket this comes from the
salad printer it's been an hour and I
got nothing read the [__] ticket oh
[__] hell here we go what the [__]
read the
ticket it's the last [__]
table Martin's lack of managerial skills
start to show so they want the lamb who
the ladies that yeah and the weight
staff becomes confused can you give it
to that table service pleas can somebody
take this please which is causing
disorder in the kitchen and everything
is starting to back up Martin KH the
food's sitting here and no one's moving
their ass yes it's getting cold and cold
and
cold oh my God how' that happen I need
another rice please service get me
Martin please yeah quickly
yeah EXC everyone's standing in it D can
you get out the rice
[Music]
please M could you sweep the rice then
rather everyone standing here yeah be
nice to do something yeah so we don't
have to send more food to the rats
that's great finally found a job oh
[__] enough even a night with a top
chef at the helm Martin's mismanagement
of his waiters has caused problems in
the kitchen and the customers are paying
the price was the
best was it's unbelievable it's cold
for I'm surprised oneone of the food
came out War it's a
nightmare okay we're now just starting
to turn these first tables but Panic set
in customers are complaining about food
being cold they and these staff are not
used to being busy especially like
this lemon rice yeah let's go rice it's
cold cuz it's [__] lying around this
take this please service
please I never served as many customers
before who's running the restaurant
Martin yeah somebody ordered this 33 I'm
not going to say anything negative about
the restaurant but I don't understand
this restaurant let's go and there you
go rather than tra right where you going
what
table what one's that for vus vus VAs I
don't think that that Martin understands
what a general manager really should be
doing don't make any phone calls along
the way straight to the
table why is that Rice going cold now
why is that be served no it's actually
burning yes it's actually burning I want
the customer to experience it hot not
your hand customers are complaining
about the food cold my man you took a
meal out just now I believe Gord is
trying to get me
angry ired annoyed or whatever and I
wasn't taking any part with
[Music]
that Gordon has seen enough of Martin's
managerial incompetence and believes he
may have found a solution be honest with
me can you manage this place yes I can
so stop blending in and stand on your
feet okay yes I can do that I will try
my best to convince Chef Ramsey that I
can run this
restaurant ready go ready everything is
One
n one minute one minute I have
to I have to put that's it that's okay
that's okay relax with con taking the
rains food is finally making it out to
the customers good man thank you
excellent for the water use the tray
take it to the down there each and every
time table 44 need there or
check perfect all the best
brother definitely try this this is
great that's like price yeah with in the
dining room and Vias in the kitchen the
restaurant is beginning to run smoothly
it was a very very good experience for
me and my whole te and then make me feel
good one 2
three tonight I made over $100 I was so
happy make sure you guys come back again
okay okay take
[Music]
care
e